House of the Dragon is an upcoming Game of
Thrones prequel series based on George R.R.
Martin’s Fire & Blood, a history of House
Targaryen set 300 years before the events
in GoT.
The show begins filming in January 2021 and
will air sometime in 2022, most likely in
April.
Set 300 years before the events of Game of
Thrones, the series tells the story of a turbulent
period for House Targaryen, one that set sibling
against sibling and dragon against dragon.
The point of contention: who should rule on
the Iron Throne, of course.
“If you’d like to know a bit more of what
the show will be about… well, I can’t
actually spill those beans,” Martin teased
in his blog, “but you might want to pick
up a copy of two anthologies I did with Gardner
Dozois, Dangerous Women, and Rogues and then
move on to Archmaester Gyldayn’s history,
Fire & Blood.”
Dangerous Women includes what press materials
describe as a “35,000-word novella” by
Martin called “The Princess and the Queen,
or, the Blacks and the Greens,” which is
“about the Dance of the Dragons, the vast
civil war that tore Westeros apart nearly
two centuries before the events of A Game
of Thrones.”
The Greens were the faction during the Dance
of the Dragons that supported the claim of
Aegon ll Targaryen, their rivals being the
Blacks, who supported the claim of Rhaenyra
Targaryen. Both were named for the color of
their clothes worn during one tourney.
Rogues, meanwhile, includes Martin’s story
“The Rogue Prince, or, a King’s Brother,”
which chronicles “the early life, adventures,
misdeeds, and marriages of Prince Daemon Targaryen,”
considered “one of the biggest rogues in
the entire history of Ice and Fire.”
Finally, the novel Fire & Blood, released
in November 2018, is the first novel of a
two-part history of the Targaryens in Westeros.
“Centuries before the events of A Game of
Thrones, House Targaryen — the only family
of dragonlords to survive the Doom of Valyria
— took up residence on Dragonstone,” according
to the book’s description on the author’s
site. “Fire & Blood begins their tale with
the legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator
of the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount
the generations of Targaryens who fought to
hold that iconic seat, all the way up to the
civil war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In addition to this, few casting calls have
been known, I’m speaking of that of Daemon
Targaryen, the Rogue Prince, further confirming
that the House of the Dragon will be about
Dance of the Dragons, the Targaryen civil
war.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
This summer, it was reported that HBO has
released a casting call for George RR Martin's
favorite Targaryen, Daemon Targaryen, key
figure from this time period of the Dance
of the Dragons.
But who really is this George RR Martin's
favorite Targaryen and how big his role will
be in the upcoming Game of Thrones prequel.
Daemon Targaryen also known as Prince of the
City, Lord Flea Bottom and the Rogue Prince
had many titles throughout his life: Prince,
Ser, Commander of the City Watch, Master of
Coin, master of laws, King of the stepstones
and the narrow sea, protector of the realm.
Daemon was the most controversial man of his
lifetime, an audacious rogue prince and adventuer
who seemed made of good and evil in equal
measure.
There was never a man so loved and so reviled,
and at the same time, as he was.
During the Dance of the Dragons, as the husband
of his niece Rhaenyra, he supported his wife's
claim, and he was considered by many the most
dangerous man in Westeros.
He was Rhaenyra's second husband, following
Ser Laenor Velaryon and she was his third
wife.
Prince Daemon was the most experienced warrior
of his time and wielded the Valyrian steel
blade Dark Sister. A dragon rider whose dragon
was Caraxes, Daemon declared himself the King
of the Stepstones and the Narrow Sea.
Daemon was a skilled warrior, described in
the histories as dashing, daring, and dangerous.
He was also ambitious, impetuous, mercurial,
amoral, reckless, and quick to take offense.
He is described as being as charming as he
was hot-tempered.
Starting from the very beginning, Daemon was
born as the second son of Prince Baelon Targaryen
and his sister-wife, Princess Alyssa Targaryen,
in 81 AC, during the reign of his grandfather,
King Jaehaerys I Targaryen. He had one older
brother, Viserys, as well as one younger brother,
Aegon.
Since his youth, Daemon's face was familiar
to every cut-purse, every lady of the night,
and every gambler in Flea Bottom. He was knighted
at sixteen, and King Jaehaerys I Targaryen
gave him Dark Sister for his martial skill
and prowess.
Daemon' first marriage was to Lady Rhea Royce,
but he disliked both her and the Vale of Arryn.
During the Great Council of 101 AC, Daemon
supported the claim of Prince Viserys, as
it would make Daemon the heir after his brother.
Daemon gathered a small army when it was rumored
that Lord Corlys Velaryon was readying a fleet
to defend the rights of his son, Laenor Velaryon,
who's mother was Rhaenys Targaryen. They would
later become closest allies.
Daemon served briefly as master of coin from
103 AC until 104 AC and master of laws for
six months after that. Governance bored Daemon.
Daemon was appointed Commander of the City
Watch of King's Landing.
Daemon inspired loyalty with many of the rank-and-file
men of the City Watch, improving their armaments
and equipment. He gave every man a golden
cloak, which led to the guards becoming known
as the gold cloaks.
Daemon developed a dark reputation for the
harsh punishments.
He became acquainted with a lady of the night
named Mysaria who would serve as his mistress
of whisperers in the streets of Flea Bottom.
While Daemon called himself the "Prince of
the City", he became known as "Lord Flea Bottom"
among the residents of King's Landing.
Daemon considered himself his brother's heir
as Viserys had no living sons, and he coveted
the title Prince of Dragonstone, which the
king refused to grant.
Viserys's first wife, Aemma Arryn, died birthing
Baelon Targaryen, Viserys's second son, the
first having died in the cradle. Baelon died
a day after his birth, however. Daemon was
observed in the Street of Silk making drunken
jokes about the "heir for a day". When word
of this reached the grieving Viserys,
the enraged king had Rhaenyra, his daughter
and Daemon's niece and future wife, declared
heir in response to his ungrateful brother's
apathy. Daemon left the capital in a fury.
On Dragonstone, Daemon impregnated his lover,
Mysaria. He wanted to present her with a dragon
egg. The angry Viserys demanded that Daemon
return the egg and that he return to his wife
in the Vale. Daemon sent Mysaria to Lys, but
Mysaria's ship sailed through a storm in the
narrow sea and Mysaria lost the child. This
hardened Daemon against his brother.
In 106 AC, Daemon led an army to invade the
Stepstones in the southern narrow sea, with
the support of Lord Corlys Velaryon and his
fleet, and with the use of Daemon's dragon,
Caraxes.
After conquering all but two of the islands,
Daemon declared himself King of the Stepstones
and the Narrow Sea in 109 AC, being crowned
by Corlys the Sea Snake.
Bored with ruling his meager kingdom, Daemon
returned to the capital of
King's Landing in 111 AC during the tourney
that gave the greens and the blacks their
names. He reconciled with Viserys I Targaryen
by offering him his Stepstones crown. Viserys
welcomed his brother's return and Daemon was
given a seat on the small council.
Neither age or exile had changed Daemon's
nature, however.
Daemon was cold with Viserys's second wife,
Queen Alicent Hightower, and her children,
who had pushed him further down in the line
of succession.
Daemon spent hours in the company of his niece,
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen, praising her
beauty, enthralling her with tales of his
adventures, giving her gifts, and mocking
her stepmother and her greens.
Six months after his return, it was rumored
that Daemon took Rhaenyra's virginity prior
to her sixteenth name day and Daemon was exiled
again.
Daemon returned to Bloodstone in the Stepstones
and resumed his struggle over his barren kingdom.
Daemon's wife, Rhea Royce, died from falling
from a horse in 115 AC. Daemon departed to
the Vale of Arryn to claim Runestone, which
had been Rhea's seat, but he was refused by
House Royce. Not welcome in the Vale, Daemon
turned to Driftmark, where he laid eyes upon
the enchanting Laena Velaryon, the beautiful
daughter of his friend, Lord Corlys. After
killing in a duel Laena's betrothed, the son
of the Sealord of Braavos, Daemon asked the
Sea Snake for his daughter's hand.
Because the marriage had been without consent
of King Viserys I Targaryen, Daemon and Laena
left Westeros, abandoned the Stepstones, and
toured the Free Cities. They remained in Pentos
for some time when they learned that Laena
was pregnant, causing their daughters Baela
and Rhaena to be born there in 116 AC. Daemon
wrote his brother begging leave to present
his daughters to court to receive a royal
blessing.
The small council advised the king to refuse,
but Viserys replied, "Daemon is a father now.
He will have changed."
After giving his 2 daughters, Daemon's second
wife Laena died in 120 AC, trying to birth
him a son who died as well.
In 120 AC Daemon married again, this time
to his niece, Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen.
This marriage was performed suddenly without
the knowledge of King Viserys I Targaryen,
and was scandalous since neither Laena nor
Laenor Velaryon, Daemon's previous wife and
Rhaenyra's previous husband, had been dead
for six months. According to Mushroom, it
was Daemon who arranged the death of Laenor
by paying Ser Correy to kill him, thus making
Rhaenyra available to marry.
Daemon and Rhaenyra had two sons together,
Prince Aegon the Younger born in 120 AC and
Prince Viserys, born in 122 AC.
While Viserys I Targaryen had decreed Rhaenyra
Targaryen his heir, Ser Criston Cole crowned
Queen Alicent Hightower's son, Aegon II Targaryen,
after Viserys's death in 129 AC.
The Greens took advantage of being in Kings
Landing at the time of the death of King Viserys
and took the throne while most of the Blacks
were at Dragonstone.
At the start of the civil war called the Dance
of the Dragons, Prince Daemon had more experience
in warfare than all their foes combined. During
Rhaenyra's rival coronation on Dragonstone,
Daemon placed the crown of King Jaehaerys
I Targaryen on the head of his wife, proclaiming
her queen and claiming himself Protector of
the Realm.
Daemon led the assault on Harrenhal, capturing
the ruined castle from its castellan.
After hearing of the death of his stepson,
Prince Lucerys Velaryon, at the hands of his
nephew, Prince Aemond Targaryen,
Daemon, through his spymaster and former mistress
Mysaria, hired Blood and Cheese to murder
a son of Aegon II. Son for a son.
Daemon abandoned Harrenhal when Aemond and
Criston began marching on the great castle
with a host of greens
Instead, Daemon flew Caraxes back to King's
Landing and assisted Rhaenyra with capturing
the city.
He made his niece and wife, Rhaenyra the Queen
of the Seven Kingdoms-
While searching for Aemond and Vhagar, who
were burning the Riverlands, Daemon took dragon
seed Nettles for a bedmate and made their
base in Maidenpool.
Maester Norren informed Daemon that Queen
Rhaenyra wanted Nettles dead because some
dragon seeds betrayed her. Daemon thanked
the maester for the warning and he and Nettles
separated the next morning.
Daemon challenged Aemond, waiting for thirteen
days at Harrenhal until Aemond stopped burning
the Riverlands to come face him.
On the 14th day just as Daemon was about to
slash a 14th mark at the heart tree in the
godswood to mark each passing day, a shadow
swept over the castle.
Vhagar had come at last and on her back
rode one-eyed Prince Aemond. He had not come
alone. Pregnant with his child, Alys Rivers
flew with him. Alys helped Aemond find Daemon
as she saw him in the fire.
The Prince helped his woman down from Vhagar's
back, then turned to face
his uncle, calling him a fool for coming to
face him alone because his dragon is the oldest
and most powerful dragon, on which Daemon
replied ''were I not alone, you would not
have come''.
Finally, Aemond says to him ''you have lived
too long'' and Daemon replies ''on that much
we agree'' before climbing their dragons.
When he climbed upon Caraxes, Daemon did not
fasten his chains that connected him.
Since Daemon's dragon was a lot younger and
smaller than Aemond's, Daemon was quickly
hidden in clouds whilst Aemon looked for him.
When Caraxes attacked Vhagar, she ripped upon
his stomach and tore one of his wings, but
then Caraxes fastened his jaws around her
throat in death grip.
These injuries forced them both to cease flying
and as they tumbled to the water below, Daemon
dueled Aemond to the death.
As he never fastened his saddle, Daemon stood
up on Caraxes and leapt at Aemond,
whereupon he drove his Dark Sister through
Aemond's eye and through his neck, just a
second before hitting the water.
The Battle Above the Gods Eye ended in the
deaths of both riders and both dragons. Daemon
was forty-nine when he died. Unlike Aemond's
body, however, Daemon's was never found. Singers
say that Daemon lived to spend the rest of
his days in secret with Nettles, but most
historians disagree.
I actually believe Daemon didn't die here,
and I have a very good theory about it which
I will post in the following days.
Daemon never achieved his ambition to sit
on the Iron Throne, though his sons Aegon
III and Viserys II eventually did.
In conclusion, House of the Dragon is coming.
Daemon Targaryen will be one of the main characters
and probably my favorite, just like he is
George RR Martin's favorite.
''Over the centuries, House Targaryen has
produced both great men and monsters. Prince
Daemon was both. In his day there was not
a man so admired, so beloved, and so reviled
in all Westeros. He was made of light and
darkness in equal parts. To some, he was a
hero, to others the blackest of villains.''
- writings of Gyldayn
This is a good description of Daemon.
The best description comes from George RR
Martin
of course:
I honestly cannot wait for House of the Dragon.
Let me know which side you're on, are you
supporting the Greens or the Blacks in the
Targaryen civil war.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you liked
this video and if you did please give it a
big thumbs up and until the next one! Peace!